oh it's just burning not in this kitchen
this is how much i love my mother-in-law
today i'm going to be cooking a haitian
plate for my haitian mother-in-law
for the first time i have high hopes
i know i've burned tortillas in the past
rice too but i'm sure this is going to
turn out amazing and she's going to love
it
but we'll let her be the judge of that
you should wear a
hair tie because your hair going to fall
all over the food
so i'm going to put my hair up let's
disregard that
so we're going to start with the easiest
thing oh my gosh
what are they called again okay
what banana
okay it's fine see this is why this is
here
protection
[Music]
no pressure she's coming right over and
then
i'm doing fine sure you're doing good
okay this hurts
you want me to show you
[Music]
okay captain america
it's ready it's definitely ready
when i do this to myself i'm going to
impress people with these the more
pressure you find
the better the better it gets
what
i'm still really good oh yeah
oh we're dipping it back inside
this is painful does your mom do this
all the time how does she deal with the
burns
you're not cooking right if it doesn't
hurt so now we're going to do
chicken and sauce which is called sauce
the traditional haitian way is to rub it
with lemon
and then you rinse it off with hot water
we're gonna make our epis
[Music]
do you get dizzy from cutting onion
oh my god hold up this is how much i
love my mother-in-law
i've got an onion for her okay
oh my god i can't see anything
[Music]
um
delicious worth every tear
i feel like it's finally starting to
come together why is it looking black
it's burning oh my gosh i think it's too
high
oh it's just burning it's burning again
come on you're not burning today not in
this kitchen
[Music]
wait why don't i stir it and let it sit
first
it looks so good wow i actually want to
eat it
i didn't think i was going to want to
eat my own food
[Music]
what do you feel about your
daughter-in-law cooking for you
for the first time that was a surprise
i'm grateful the rice look like
you need a little bit of clc
the plant and i like the plantain you
know i can see you know
something is good it's well done
[Music]
that's good and let's go for the meat
very good the rice the main dish
[Music]
the mother of the asian food
the rice is not cooked well completely
fully just to be honest that's my honest
opinion
a little bit of more salt you know and
yes there is no salt in there at
all you have to rate the plantain one
through ten
what would you rate it eight how about
the chicken uh
very good a good nine and then the rice
i will give you fall for an effort
when we're having party at home she will
cook the chicken
going to work on the rice though thank
you it's time to clean now gracias
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is